大家好 我是Ceo
我們現在在解放村開過夜
像我自己個人因為很喜歡跑咖啡廳喝咖啡這樣
然後我喜歡有景色的地方
然後因為解放村是在一個比較高的山上
所以我們看出去的時候就基本上全部都是景
我們要從聖水轉到解放村要搭兩班公車
所以現在站在等車
那等公車的時間呢來介紹一下今天的OOTD
今天的OOTD呢就是外面一件牛仔外套
然後其實衣服基本上已經要重複了
可是每天還是有點不同的搭配
然後一件黑色襯衫
然後裡面一件粉絲襯衫
其實買的
我覺得它就是一個
非常舒服非常適合就是夏天天氣的褲子
我買了兩件吧
因為跳舞也可以穿
教課也可以穿
然後日常穿都OK的程度
岩山塔到了
先要來點餐了
我們Ice Americano的漢醬 있고요
然後請給我一盤阿蒙德曲奇
可以調高一點嗎
可以
剛才沒有黑咖啡真的是不行
這裡就是黑棒村
以前的這一間咖啡廳我非常的喜歡
因為這一間還有樓梯
天氣超好的話還可以看得到夕陽
之外有一些文青小店
這邊就有衣服店
有些咖啡廳我知道
但是我還沒有來過
我們意外經過了
愛情什麼翻譯的拍攝景點
喔 原來他們是在這裡吃飯的啊
要記住這間店喔 下次來吧
這間店我也是第一次來
之前好像開滿久的
但我每次都是經過 然後沒有來過
算是 我好像是第一次在韓國吃泰式的感覺
等一下來吃吃看
牛肉河粉的概念
看起來很好吃耶 很香耶
這看起來超厲害的耶
我最喜歡歐金蘿了
大概就是Olive Young旁邊呢
有一間Rendez-Vous
買了一個就是最近Arnois真的非常的紅
然後這個呢是PDRN的噴霧
我找它其實找滿久的
因為一般Olive Young其實沒有賣這種小噴霧
它的質地呢就是非常的細緻
然後一搖
是非常的方便
然後又可以滿保濕的這樣什麼
因為其實我真的來Olive Young太多次了
所以其實我對Olive Young的東西
某種程度來說還滿熟的
而這個是我這趟買的新東西
原本沒有
然後其實因為它是惠麗代言的
所以就是因為它是惠麗代言的
所以我才就想說
欸 有興趣喔 好像可以買一下
然後剛剛好呢
我的就是卸妝已經要用完了
所以我就試著看看
想說欸 那用用看新的牌子
結果它的卸妝油超讚的欸
它的卸妝油是那種就是超級不油的卸妝油
就是 然後我朋友就跟我說
好的卸妝油通常都不會油
因為我是一個非常容易長痘痘的人
所以我覺得就是如果卸妝油太油的話
我就不行
但是這個卸妝油超清爽
然後重點是它的就是卸妝油清爽就算囉
它的洗面乳洗完
對毛孔超級乾淨
惠麗代言的好
真的是不錯
我剛剛去買了一個PDRN的
如果你有看我可能
Maybe前幾天的影片的話
你會看得到
其實就是一個保養品
但是它是在點上妝之前
然後使用的保養品
然後拍一拍
它很像洗面乳
然後當它就是上上去之後
然後你的臉就會變得保濕度非常高
然後妝會變得非常的服貼
其實我今天也有用
剛剛買了這個
這個我其實用過非常多個
就是因為我太容易長痘痘了
痘痘貼裡面有微增的痘痘貼
帶回台灣 然後囤貨這樣
剛剛看起來好像
就是我不知道它有沒有名
但是就是我剛剛看
它是可以就是整理頭髮用的
然後我剛剛頭髮有稍微的整理一下
然後我就發現說它比較
不會那麼的毛躁
我覺得滿好的
想說如果我那麼常來整理頭髮
然後不想要讓它看起來毛毛躁躁
因為我自然捲
所以就覺得這個好像蠻值得買的
剛剛現場試用了一下
安安姊姊
哈囉
安安
我們SELU的朋友在這裡
要去逛一個就是Locasi
迎接新朋友之後
要去帶她去逛的第一間店
很久沒來韓國了齁
十年了
等一下再看要吃什麼
她說不要吃身上會太臭的東西
我滿喜歡的店
那天剛好路過沒有逛到
有我的帽子
我覺得他們這一系列超可愛的
我有這一頂
所以它好像上一季就是做了一個系列
都是跟Teddy Bear
喔 真的喔
它還酷
彈妞
很行欸
這個顏色很可愛對不對
這顏色很可愛耶
我們姊姊買了新的帽子
喔 這個顏色好可愛喔
這個購物袋
我們晚餐的行程呢
又來吃馬鈴薯湯啦
這間我已經吃過N百次了吧
中國人 本地人
或者是觀光客都會來的地方
看起來好好吃喔
有杜拜巧克力耶
我的是杜拜巧克力
耶!
吃吃看
真的好吃
隨便攔
攔車虎眼
好好吃喔
準備要回家啦
今天Crystal走了之後
然後換一個新朋友一起逛街
然後我們剛剛買了什麼呢
Artiste跟那個Burrish的內衣
然後Artiste的帽子
然後跟Low Classic的帽子
我明天繼續
就明天見啦
掰掰